what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to love
sosa with my little sister amelia she is
14
years old say hi you said i was 12
earlier okay i
forgot could you just just how can you
forget can you just say hi
you're bullying me okay so when i
was talking to her earlier she said that
she had never heard of this song
which i thought that was a travesty
because this is a national anthem
so i listened to lemony when you expect
me to listen
okay well just
um
[Music]
i don't know maybe it's hot it's not
okay so do you understand the beginning
of the song
i have no idea what he said okay so he
said these [ __ ] love
sosa so sosa's the rapper so he's saying
that the girls love him
i'm sure some people don't but i mean
that's his opinion so
okay
[Music]
head on with that call bro now that
what's up though
but they doing
[Music]
i would love to be invited to a party
[Music]
[Music]
did you hear that part no okay so he's
saying
that if you disrespect the oh boys and
oh block
is a a part of chicago where this gang
lives does that make sense
um and basically so you're saying if you
disrespect
like the old boys like my gang we won't
speak again and he's not just talking
about
in person he's saying you might die
okay okay any questions
no no we we will continue don't think
that i'm playing
you hear that no we don't use hands
cause they use guns
hear that he's saying i could your mama
i feel like you wouldn't want to touch
her
okay it's song it's drama
you give me my love
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why do they keep mentioning a cobra i
don't know what that means
[Music]
[Music]
do you know what it means when he says
she's gonna clap for sosa i don't really
care
okay well i have to explain it to you
because that's what we're doing it's
like a lyrical analysis
okay so he it's basically saying he's
gonna hook up with a girl
okay and that's not my problem
what did you tell you were doing for the
video still not my problem
[Music]
so [ __ ] be cool like water for you get
hit with this life
[Music]
[Music]
so they said we got a lot of dope do you
know what that means
probably drugs good job
okay just finish it just finish it
finish it give me that don't let me hang
in
[Music]
okay guys that was so fun um amelia was
so excited to spend time with me tonight
right right amelia
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel guys before i end the video
um on a scale of one to five i'm gonna
give that a five obviously that is a
national anthem
what did you think one to five
okay she doesn't care um
okay and while you're at it do not
forget to bring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos i will talk to you guys
next time